hi
i'm vishwanathan anand five-time world
chess champion
and this is one of my favorite moves so
this is a game between me and joel
lottie
we played it in the first round of the
bill
chess tournament in 1997 and um
it was a very good start to the
tournament i mean if you play a game
like this
uh you feel very good with yourself
for the coming rounds and that's a nice
feeling to have
there was a lot of creative satisfaction
to this game
uh briefly i would say that
the interesting story was that a year
and a half after
my using the scandinavian against
kasparov in the world championship
joel kind of challenged me to it
from the black pieces
and now we come to my favorite move so
the
logic behind it is that if i play bishop
g6
he can play queen takes d1
now i have two ways i can go bishop
takes f7 check
king f8 bishop a3 check
but then 97
bishop e7 king takes f7
i mean this position is probably even
good for white i don't know but
you know i've spoiled it a little bit
and
that didn't seem very convincing to me
and the question is how could i improve
this
and then i found a very quiet move which
oh let me just finish the line here
there is also rook takes e6 check
because king f8 rook takes f7 check
king j8 and i have run out of steam my
attack has stopped
if i go bishop a3 check that's very nice
because if he goes king f8 i have
a king g8 i have made the problem is he
does knight e7
and i'm all over him i have two rooks
and a bishop able to take on e7 and
there are multiple mating threats but
the problem is it will be black's move
for one move and in that time he can
play queen takes f3
over here or queen f1
and my king will have to run around so
just a bit tad bit premature
and then i found a move with just uh you
know that quiet pawn move
the silent killer it just
[Music]
gives the move to black but it's not
easy to find a way for black
and this is the move that i found and it
is one of my favorite moves
um i like this move very much i'll show
you why let's look at a couple of
variations
let's say black plays g5
then i'll go bishop g6 queen takes d1
and you'll say well what's the
difference well here it is
i take king goes there
i take and in difference with the other
line
now i have rook g7 check because it's
now defended
and here bishop a3 and it's going to be
made
so that's one thing g6 same thing bishop
takes g6 that rook goes to g7 and bishop
a3 exact same thing
and in fact he should have captured here
and after this i'm much better sorry let
me throw this one in
he goes here and then i just go here and
i'm much better because i'll have two
bishops
his king is a bit open and
well i have the two bishops so um
that was his best chance but he did g
head six
and this gave me a chance to execute my
idea
bishop g6 um
honestly both these moves are lovely but
head six is the one that set this one up
uh make up it was what you will
if he now takes i go
bishop f7 check oh sorry i go rookie six
check
[Music]
king f8 bishop at six check that's the
difference but that's why i had to play
g5 i mean hit six and then i go bishop
takes f7 mate
anyway thanks for watching i hope you
enjoyed this move
it's one of my favorite moves it paid my
best games collection
and i hope you enjoy it and check out
the game as well
there are some nice tactics in there
have fun
[Music]
you